you've been all over the the rumor mill
this week but what the hell is going on
with you and housewives
can you set clear the air you're not
quitting the show right you know what I
haven't said anything for two months now
everybody's been talking about this I've
just been going about my business and
doing my things I am in the show
I have not quit and if I did quit it
wouldn't just be kind of a leak story I
would be upfront and honest but I have a
lot of you know loyalty to the
production company and the network but
it has been a difficult season but it's
been a difficult year for me personally
and the season was very challenging so
I'm in a lot of it but there are some
parts I skip and I think you know people
have seen that I was with Kyle last week
and she said she loves you but she
hasn't talked to you in a while why is
that you know I don't think you can
actually explain something I think
that's what's fascinating about the show
because you see the build-up you see the
story you go on the journey and for me
to say well this happened and you know
it would be kind of cheating you really
you need to go on the journey do you
think this will be your final season or
does that remain to be seen I think
that's like saying am I invited to your
Christmas party next year we never know
you know is Luke oh does the show get
picked up do they want the same people
back we never know so I'm just
concentrate on this season Lisa
Vanderpump is concentrating on a lot
these days
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
Vanderpump rules a new restaurant in
Vegas and her true passion giving back
to dogs
et spoke with LVP at her annual
Vanderpump dogs gala third year for this
and I feel like I was a different energy
this year because of what has just
happened in California and that's you
know a huge consideration for us you
know to have the garlic but we've
planned it so far in advance and our
foundation has been working hard to you
know help with the rescue situation so
you know portion of the profits tonight
will go to help some of the rescue dogs
as well when you see everybody who's
here to support this look at out this
night what does this all mean to you for
a nation of dog lovers and I think
everybody knows our cause is really
truly authentic it comes from a place of
love I think it's got a feel-good factor
to it you have immediate gratification
you see all these dogs have been rescued
I really want to thank all the people
that have to notice about Dog Foundation
because you know their money it really
kind of it really helps the situation
because we have grown so much as a
rescue center with people supporting us
people take on so many more dogs I mean
the first year it was just cannon eyed
trying to do it but now it's kind of
grown we've got a lot more people
working for us and we've saved already
over 750 dogs that's what you're going
to celebrate tonight I will let you get
in there and have fun you have a great
night so good to see you
[Music]